both you guys have worked with director
Joss Whedon before what was unique and
different about coming back and working
with him this time around we did one
take throughout the entire movie was a
real different different it's a big like
truly one day he did yeah when I was
just thank you what's different um you
know I mean working with Joss is always
such a treat the experience is sort of
the same one-on-one but I think you know
he's such a marvelous director and I
think that this film just now speaks to
his ability to like take on just this
massive project and to be able to go
like okay this is my story and these are
my characters but also through all these
other elements in terms of special
effects and the scale of this is so
massive and he was able to show up to
work and be a good mood and like be able
to have a discussion about a character
as well as dealing with all this other
stuff
now Jeremy you were able to shoot on a
lot of different locations around the
world how was that able to either help
or hinder you it as an actor in the
performance you were able to bring well
you know anytime you any any of us can
be on a real set or real location versus
any you know fake background or the CGI
backgrounds it always helps us with
props and everything and yeah shooting
in Italy for the in sequence was amazing
because all that for wherever we were
for for Erin and Lizzie myself in that
section of the movie was oh there man I
mean everything outside of I can't say
the spoiler of it but you know the city
doing its thing that man is like it was
amazing I mean it's it was one of the
most beautiful sets I've ever been on in
the sense of how tragic it was the
buildings are falling and they weren't
even throwing there was anything like
CGI you know meteors or wherever coming
down it's just like they were literally
physically throwing foam rocks but with
like just coming off I was like this is
really happening right now it's amazing
it was it was a full travesty happening
around you were living in it so it makes
it so easy to run around and do what was
supposed to
- and chaos is so fantastic and there
was literally no robots or bad guys
running around but it still felt chaotic
is amazing and then in the start our
it's it was in in London again one of
the most exotic sets in opulent I mean
there was it was amazing I mean I never
everyone wanted to live in this in this
sad it was so beautiful
I've never seen anything really quite
like it in any job I've ever done the
sets were just fantastic and I rarely
had to do to green screen without on the
woods I mean just really tremendous and
we really had I had so much fun being in
those locations now after Captain
America Winter Soldier Maria is in a
very different place now tell us a
little bit about where we find her and
you know who she's working with now and
what we can expect for her as we move
into the next Avengers film yes
well shield has been dismantled and
Moreno has sought employment with Tony
Stark at the Avengers Tower and so you
know she's she's kind of running the
show there and she doesn't have shield
at her disposal anymore so she's it's
like much heavier workload and she's
sort of in charge of the Avengers and
and the different missions that they go
on and and navigating Tony Stark
you